komm lauf hört zu das alles sind
imperativ formen und mit diesem
imperativ drückt man im deutschen bitten
befehle und aufforderungen aus man
möchte also dass eine andere person
etwas bestimmtes macht dieser imperativ
ist vor allem ein phänomen der
gesprochenen sprache und die form
unterscheidet sich ein bisschen von der
normalen konjugation ich sage zum
beispiel in der normalen konjugation du
gehst du gehst weg zum beispiel im
imperativ sage ich geh weg in beiden
fällen adressiere ich also diese zweite
person aber die form ist unterschiedlich
und genau das möchten wir euch heute im
video zeigen wir zeigen euch wie man
diese imperativ form im deutschen bildet
los geht's ihr kennt wahrscheinlich die
ganz normale verb konjugation im
deutschen ich gehe
du gehst er geht wir gehen und im
imperativ gibt es tatsächlich nur vier
formen die teilweise etwas abweichend
von der normalen konjugation man kann
den imperativ an einzelne personen
richten dann sagt man zum beispiel im
informellen gehweg und informellen gehen
sie weg und man kann den imperativ auch
an gruppen richten dann sagt man im
informellen geht weg und informellen
gehen sie weg das heißt die formelle
version ist tatsächlich im singular und
plural gleich
janosch kann man bitte ich kann jetzt
nicht ich spiele
bitte guck mal nur ganz kurz
das geht nicht ich spiele ist gegen die
roboter
die
hatte
in dieser szene habt ihr gesehen wie ich
janisch mehrfach zu etwas auf fordere
ich sag zu janisch komm mal oder guckt
doch mal und dann sagt janisch zu mir
geh weg das alles sind imperativ formen
dieses comco ag
wie bildet man diese imperativ form man
bildet die immer so dass man den verb
stamm nimmt also ihr kennt ja die
konjugation ich komme du kommst er kommt
und diese änderung lässt man einfach weg
so dass man nur den stamm hat komm komm
her bedeutet also kam hier und noch
etwas was ihr in dem beispiel eben
gehört habt ist dieses kleine wort mal
dieses mal ist ein sogenannter modal
partikel und timo dahl partikel die
benutzt man vor allem in der
gesprochenen sprache wir haben dazu
schon mal ein ganzes video gemacht dass
ihr hier findet und ihr hört dieses mal
auch ganz oft mit einem imperativ wenn
manchmal klingt ein imperativ alleine
ein bisschen unhöflich wenn ich einfach
sage kommen ja noch klingt das ein
bisschen unhöflich und durch dieses mal
mache ich das ein bisschen freundlicher
komm mal janisch
hallo janos wann sollen wir morgen
vorbei kommt herr eric kommt so gegen 17
uhr ich werde lecker suppe kochen
das ist super dann bis morgen in dieser
szene habt ihr die plural form des
interaktiv kennengelernt eric fragt
janisch waren er und seine freunde
morgen vorbei kommen sollen organisch
antwortet kommt einfach um 17 uhr das
ist also diese imperativ form im plural
kommt und sie ist ganz einfach zu merken
denn sie ist eigentlich genauso wie die
normale konjugierte form in der zweiten
person plural man sagt ihr kommt morgen
um 17 uhr in einem normalen aussage satz
und als aufforderung sage ich kommt hier
lasse ich also das pronomen weg kommt
morgen vorbei
[Musik]
ja bitte
guten tag ich möchte ihnen gerne einen
staubsauger verkaufen
hören sie ich habe jetzt keine zeit aber
ich habe ein echtes top angebot für sie
ich verkaufe ihnen den robo king 8000
für nur 299 euro hast du sehr auf ich
bin jetzt mitten in dein spiel
es handelt sich um einen
staubsaugerroboter
das kind
also der kann ganz von alleine
staubsaugen ok schicken sie mir zu
in diesem wunderschönen dialog habt ihr
den imperativ in der formellen version
kennengelernt also in der sie form und
hier habt ihr gehört wie man den
imperativ in der sie vorm bildet das ist
nämlich ganz einfach die form bleibt
tatsächlich genauso man dreht nur die
reihenfolge von web und subjekt um
janisch hat zum beispiel gesagt schicken
sie mir den staubsauger zu der normale
aussage satz wäre sie schicken mir den
staubsauger zu und wenn ich das als
aufforderung formuliere dann sage ich
einfach schicken sie mir den staubsauger
oder hören sie mir zu
wenn ihr noch mehr zu den deutschen
werben lernen möchtet dann probiert doch
mal den vokabeltrainer in unserer app
ceiling aus dort gibt es die 6.000
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln und ihr
könnt dort zum beispiel die wichtigsten
werben mit verschiedenen übungen lernen
probiert das mal aus aussiedlung dot com
oder im app store und google place tor
findet ihr die app auch unterschiedlich
auch im imperativ gibt es
unregelmäßige verb formen zum beispiel
gibt es einige werben die haben in der
zweiten person singular 1 ihr kennt zum
beispiel das verb essen und man sagt
aber du bist und nicht du erst und diese
sea bleibt auch im imperativ bestehen
wenn ich zum beispiel zu dir etwas sagen
möchte als aufforderung dann sage ich
ist schneller
zum beispiel
damit ist noch nicht so schnell
in dieser szene habt ihr gesehen wie ich
zu janisch gesagt habe ist nicht so
schnell und dieses gleiche phänomen mit
dem ihr habt ihr auch in weiteren werben
zum beispiel sehen geben und lesen ich
sagt zum beispiel gib mir das oder ließ
das x oder sie mal da drüben
es gibt noch eine andere ausnahme bei
der bildung des imperativs wenn eine
imperativ form auf die buchstaben
tdm oder enden würde dann hängen wir
nämlich tatsächlich noch ein ehe hinten
dran ein beispiel ist das wort arbeiten
der werkstattarbeit ich sage arbeite
arbeitest und dieser werkstatt alleine
der würde klingen arbeit schneller und
das wahrsagen wir tatsächlich nicht wir
fügen hier ein e an das ende denn das
klingt ein bisschen besser und flüssiger
arbeiten mal schneller könnte ich zum
beispiel im imperativ sagen
[Musik]
doch vor 50 jahren
bestätigt ein bisschen hinterher
in unserer letzten szene für heute habt
ihr ein weiteres unregelmäßiges verb
gesehen dass den imperativ auf eine
besondere weise bildet ich sage zu
janisch sei doch mal vorsichtig und
dieses sei ist tatsächlich der imperativ
vom verb sein hier seht ihr also dieses
sei ist ganz anders als die normale
konjugation ich sage ich bin du bist er
ist und im imperativ sage ich aber sei
bitte ruhig oder sie bitte vorsichtig im
plural sage ich seit bitte ruhig oder
seid bitte vorsichtig und zwei weitere
häufig genutzte unregelmäßige verben
sind haben und werdet werden hier würde
ich sagen habt keine angst und wird
schnell wieder gesund
zum abschluss haben wir noch eine
aufforderung für euch nämlich werdet ein
mitglied bei easy germany als mitglied
könnt ihr nämlich interaktive übungen
machen auch zu diesem thema heute wenn
ihr also mal üben möchte wie man den
imperativ zu verschiedenen werben bildet
dann schaut euch das an werdet ein
mitglied von easy german der link ist
hier und hier gleich eingeblendet und
dann könnt ihr mehr zu dem thema
imperativ üben dankeschön fürs zu sehen
und wenn ihr noch weitere
themenvorschläge habt dann schreibt die
gerne hier unten in die kommentare
tschüss und bis bald
so
[Musik]